[Music]
every tv show has to come to an end
eventually some end of the creator's own
accord even more are cancelled by the
network that airs them here are some of
the saddest reasons ever that tv shows
were forced to end their runs
covet 19 put a nearly uniform stop to
most of show business along with the
rest of the world almost every tv and
movie production came to a screeching
halt many projects got pushed back and
at least one was cancelled
mid-production netflix wrestling dramedy
glow even though it had several
unresolved storylines the show was
cancelled because of the unique
difficulties it presented glow was three
weeks into filming its fourth season
when the world changed in march 2020
netflix spent the next seven months
trying to find a safe way to restart
production but the particular
circumstances were too difficult to
overcome the show was shot in los
angeles a coveted hot spot in and of
itself even worse the show's core was
wrestling an activity that requires
physical contact and heavy breathing in
close quarters combine all this with the
show being a high budget ensemble piece
with about 20 principal cast members and
netflix just couldn't find a way to make
it work safely deadline broke the
inevitable news on october 5th 2020
netflix has cancelled glo series
creators liz flahert and carly mench
shared
kovit has killed actual humans it's a
national tragedy and should be our focus
kovit also apparently took down our show
thankfully there are no reports of
anyone involved in the production
catching kovid and all the series
regulars were paid in full the cast has
since expressed interest in a
feature-length movie to wrap up the
story
robert shimmel's life was more tragedy
than comedy up to and including his 2010
death in a car accident one such tragedy
was the story surrounding his planned
sitcom shimmel and how it never got past
the pilot in 1999 shimmel signed on to
do a sitcom with 20th century fox mike
scully executive producer of the
simpsons was set to have a hand in it a
pilot was shot in which a very young
brie larson played his daughter and got
picked up by the fox network in 2000.
mere days after the announcement however
shimmel was diagnosed with non-hodgkin's
lymphoma and given six months to live
production on his sitcom stopped while
he went into treatment and he managed to
make a full recovery
variety reported in january 2001 that
production was intended to resume but
the network axed it after the schedule
got a little too crowded the pilot's
cold open surfaced on youtube in 2006
and shimmel posted some outtakes to his
facebook page in august 2010
friend me announced in early 2012 was to
follow two friends who moved from
indiana to los angeles to work at
groupon how they ended up with that show
title for characters in that line of
work remains a mystery attached to star
wars christopher mintz ploss yeah
mclovin
i am mclovin
also attached was nicholas braun he
would insist on venturing out into their
new city while the other would remain a
homebody trying to keep his midwest
roots unfortunately due to real-life
tragedy it never made it to air friend
me was co-created by alan kirschenbach a
veteran tv writer who is best known as
the creator of yes dear in october 2012
kirshenbaum was found dead in his home
of a suspected suicide this among many
other things put the show which had yet
to debut in a state of limbo after
months of delays and uncertainty then
cbs president les moonves confirmed at
an august 2013 tca press event that
there were no plans to show or burn off
the episodes as such the show remains
unaired to this day
few doctor who spin-offs were more
enduring than the sarah jane adventures
investigative journalist sarah jane
smith played by elizabeth sladen was one
of the longest tenured characters on
television this made all the more
impressive that she came from a series
marked entirely by change the sarah jane
adventures was aimed at a young audience
and followed sarah jane on her
investigative alien journeys
i saw amazing things out there in space
the show was a huge hit and it was
stopped by the only thing that could
have stopped it sladen's death producer
brian mentioned told doctor who magazine
in 2016 that the bbc loved the show and
expected to get more seasons after the
current one wrapped then in early 2011
sladen called producer russell t davies
and informed him that she had cancer and
didn't have long to live the crew over
100 people kept it secret between the
death of their star in the ensuing
heartbreak all parties involved decided
to regretfully end the show mention did
have a curious note though
russell emailed me not so long ago
saying we shouldn't have stopped should
we he thinks we cancelled the show out
of shock and he's right it was such a
lovely show and liz was fantastic on
april 19th 2020 the nine-year
anniversary of her death davies put
together a final episode farewell sarah
jane which depicted a memorial service
for the title character
grace under fire was one of the first
big hits from tv mega producer chuck
laurie the show starred brett butler's
grace a single mother raising her kids
after a divorce grace was a recovering
alcoholic while butler herself was
anything but recovered this caused
problems for her and everyone around her
which ultimately ended the show butler
became infamous for her volatile
backstage behavior with a bad
temperament and a drug addiction that
kept feeding off each other she was
known for berating her co-workers which
led to five executive producers over a
mere five years and the departure of two
cast members entertainment weekly
reported that the low point was vegas a
crossover event with other popular
sitcoms production teams for the other
shows were mortified by her behavior
which often delayed production on top of
her erratic behavior were her trips to
rehab for painkiller addiction each
visit stopped production dropped ratings
and just added to the frustration one of
these trips was part way through season
five unable to handle butler's erratic
behavior anymore abc shut down the show
according to the orlando sentinel the
production company claimed we have
decided to suspend production so that
brett may have time to resolve some
personal issues
production never resumed
megan once a millionaire was one of
about a billion d-list celebrity dating
shows from the late 2000s it starred
former rock of love contestant megan
hauserman who had a bunch of
millionaires compete to make her a
trophy wife but the show got cancelled
before the end of the first season after
one of the contestants killed himself
and someone else the contestant in
question was real estate investor ryan
jenkins the entire series was in the can
by the time he committed the crime so we
know he came in third not long after he
wrapped his part in the series he
married a woman named jasmine fiore only
for the two to later separate jenkins
joined the cast of isle of money season
3. fiore's body which the new york times
described as mutilated was found in late
april 2009 and jenkins fled to canada
after getting charged with killing her
vh1 promptly canceled megan wants a
millionaire and left the last few
episodes on air jenkins was later found
dead in a motel in hope british columbia
of an apparent suicide i love money
season 3 was also preemptively pulled
never airing an episode
ellen was a hit sitcom in its time but
it will always be remembered for one
thing the puppy episode it saw the main
character ellen played by ellen
degeneres come out of the closet not
long after degeneres herself did in real
life the puppy episode drew monster
ratings and got massive publicity but it
also marked the beginning of the end for
the show going forward degeneres and abc
clashed behind the scenes the new york
times reported that abc tried to limit
the number of lgbtq storylines and even
at one time slapped a special viewers
advisory in front of the show degeneres
was quick to point out that shows about
heterosexual relationships had no such
warning glad media director chaz bono
noted to variety the dangers in the show
becoming quote to lgbtq especially after
it became important to the plots he said
this is network prime time when a show
treats gay issues over and over again it
becomes a gay show and the average
viewer says hey i'm not gay i'm not
going to watch it the show's ratings
declined and it's certainly possible
that the audience and networks weren't
quite ready if the show's cancellation
wasn't proof enough of this the hits
that laura dern's career took was durn
whose character made ellen realize that
she was gay started getting death
threats dern hit a career peak with
jurassic park but the backlash to the
puppy episode meant that she stopped
getting offered roles for a significant
period of time
in 2017 cbs aired a sequel series to the
classic denzel washington film training
day the show was clearly meant to be a
major cornerstone for the network the
production team included antoine fuqua
the director of the movie and producer
jerry bruckheimer and had a legit star
in bill paxton nonetheless the show only
garnered modest ratings not exactly a
smash hit then the show hit a bigger
issue after four episodes aired bill
paxton died at the age of 61. all 13
episodes were in the can at the time so
production wasn't impeded but that was a
small consolation given the sudden death
of the well-liked star many sources
including deadline predicted that
paxton's death guaranteed the show
wouldn't get another season this proved
accurate there was a small uptick in
ratings after his death before they
tanked training day already had a weak
path forward one that turned impossible
without paxton
the duggar family all 19 kids and
counting made tlc a lot of money over
the course of two shows both of these
shows ended due to abrupt and upsetting
circumstances the first show 19 kids
encountering ran on the network from
2008 to 2015. viewers got to know the
duggar family devout baptists who didn't
use birth control and ended up with a
massive religious homeschooled clan the
show ended abruptly after it was
revealed that josh duggar one of the
sons molested five girls over several
years made more sickening by the fact
that four of them were his own sisters
tlc went to the well again with the
spin-off counting on this show which ran
from 2015 to 2020 originally followed
some of the older duggar siblings before
roping in the rest of the family this
too was cancelled due to josh duggar as
if his previous actions weren't
disgusting enough he now faces federal
charges for receiving and possessing
child sexually abusive material even
though he wasn't part of the show the
name and the publicity was too much for
all involved especially the network to
deal with in public
the jeremy kyle show was one of the
longest running tabloid talk shows in
the uk for those unfamiliar take a
minute to imagine the jerry springer
show for a class of people who calls
french fries chips in typical tabloid
talk fashion things often got
controversial violent and embarrassing a
popular tool on the show was lie
detector and it was one such segment
that led to the show finally getting
cancelled during the first week of may
2019 a man named steve diamond went on
the jeremy kyle show to prove that he
hadn't cheated on his ex-partner diamond
failed the lie detector test and kyle
mocked him family and friends report
that diamond who was already diagnosed
with depression and on medication was
distressed and humiliated on may 9th
diamond was found dead in his home of a
morphine overdose which many suspected
to be a suicide the itv network put out
a statement expressing sympathies for
diamond's family and said given the
gravity of recent events we have decided
to end production of the jeremy kyle
show
if you or anyone you know is having
suicidal thoughts please call the
national suicide prevention hotline at
1-800-273-talk or 1-800-273-8255
[Music]